[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
all of a sudden it's pretty easy for
people to move around the world and all
of a sudden they are
poor people moving from poor countries
across the globe into rich countries why
wouldn't they and again
that's what's happening back in 2015
more than a million illegal migrants
flooded into europe and many of them
came to hungary where we are right now
it was a crisis for the continent but
alone in europe
hungary figured out how to solve that
problem in a way that we have not
figured out here in the united states
how did hungary do that how did it
preserve its borders and its society
what can we learn from that today we
took a trip to find out we'll show you
what we found in just a minute
also the woes for the country's
creepiest governor that would be
governor andrew cuomo of new york
are compounded today getting even more
painful and yet at the same time more
amusing
he's even being stabbed in the front by
his allies at cnn we've got that tape
for you
but first tonight good evening welcome
chuck carlson tonight
on new year's day of this year rachelle
wolenski was just a college professor in
massachusetts you've almost certainly
never heard of her you definitely didn't
vote for her at any point because
wolinski had never run for office
as of january 1st her political power
was precisely the same
as yours and everyone else's in the
supposedly self-governing republic
rachelle wolinski had one vote out of a
nation of 320 million people
and then just a few weeks later
everything changed for her
and for the rest of us joe biden
appointed wallensky to run the centers
for disease control and prevention in
atlanta
at the time it did not seem like a huge
deal the cdc is not a legislative body
it's a public health bureau
it was originally designed to fight
malaria and it did a good job
the cdc now gathers information about
diseases and then releases
guidance about those diseases to the
public that's what it does
the cdc does not make laws in this
country it's not allowed to
under the us constitution making laws is
the exclusive role of the congress
you vote for your senators and your
congressmen and they decide what the
rules are
that's known as representative democracy
it's been our system for nearly two
hundred and fifty years
but apparently it's now over rochelle
wolenski now makes our laws
wellenski announced today that she has
decided to nationalize america's rental
properties
millions and millions of them from maine
to california
tenants are no longer required to pay
their rent property owners cannot evict
them under any circumstances
making someone pay to live on your
property is now a federal crime
try it and you can wind up in prison
with hundreds of thousands of dollars in
fines
at the same time you should know
property owners will still be required
to pay the banks that hold their
mortgages
there is no moratorium on mortgages
why the banks are huge democratic donors
and they're getting the treatment that
they paid for
sandy cortez and the squad are not
calling for the banks to do their part
so they're not it's property owners who
will suffer many of the members of the
rapidly disappearing american middle
class
it's hard to overstate what a momentous
change this is
it means among other things that private
property no longer exists in the united
states
you thought you owned your home not
anymore rochelle willenski does she'll
decide who can live there under what
circumstances
and for how long is this a good idea
of course not it's totalitarian but
there's an even more pressing question
at the center
of this a principle a principle that
defines what kind of country this is
and what kind of country it will be
going forward and the question is this
where did rochelle walinski get the
power to do this to suspend private
property rights in america
and the answer is she simply asserted
the power
wallenski claimed she had the authority
and no one stopped her from exercising
it this morning she signed an official
looking order declaring that her opinion
is now the law and so it is the law but
wait you say
that doesn't seem very american
shouldn't somebody vote on this
if we're going to continue to pretend
this is a democracy and you hear that on
television constantly
then shouldn't our elected lawmakers
make the laws
no and they're not going to nancy pelosi
has refused to call a vote on the matter
and she runs the congress
she decides meanwhile most republicans
haven't said a word about it
and that means that an unelected college
professor you'd never heard of six
months ago
is now in charge of your country if
you're wondering how all of this can
possibly be legal rest assured that it's
not legal it's not even
arguably legal we know that for a fact
the supreme court has just ruled on this
specific question
the court found that the cdc does not
have the right to institute a nationwide
eviction moratorium
period only congress can do that
now the court didn't make his guess on
their view of this the court put this in
writing in the clearest possible
language
there's no debate about that the biden
administration
just ignored what the court said how can
they do that
well congresswoman maxine waters of los
angeles understands exactly how they did
it
waters is hardly a genius it's likely
she's never read an entire book
but one thing maxine waters knows very
well is how third world regimes
operate when you want something you
simply take it
you've got the guns who's going to stop
you
might makes right the fidel castro
method waters explained that
out loud today as she pushed rachelle
wolenski to suspend private property
quote i don't buy that the cdc can't
extend the eviction moratorium waters
wrote on twitter
perfectly aware as she did that the
supreme court has already prohibited
this
who's going to stop them who's going to
penalize them
well good question nobody and nancy
pelosi knows that too
pelosi knows that what rachelle lewinsky
just did is illegal by definition
she also understands that openly
ignoring a supreme court ruling
will mean the end of our current system
and that's fine with nancy pelosi
quote the cdc has the power to extend
the eviction moratorium pelosi said
so she didn't explain where that power
might come from
she simply declared that it exists as
dictators do
keep in mind that even joe biden who
knows very little knows that what his
administration has just done
is against the law he said that on
camera yesterday
i've sought out constitutional scholars
to determine what is the best
possibility
that would come from executive action or
the cdc's judgment
what could they do that was most likely
to pass
muster constitutionally
the bulk of the constitutional
scholarship
says that it's not likely to pass
constitutional muster
number one but there are several key
scholars
who think that it may and it's worth the
effort
the eviction moratorium has been in
place for months
it has just been extended as of today
so people have debated this jurists
have weighed in on it and so we know it
won't quote
pass constitutional muster says joe
biden in other words
it's illegal the people doing it
are criminals that's the word we use for
people who knowingly break the law
but like most criminals are not
embarrassed by breaking the law
that's what they do watch joe biden's
senior adviser a thoroughly oily
character called gene sperling
tell you that the rule of law just isn't
relevant here
to date uh uh the cdc director
and her team have been unable to find
legal authority
even for a more targeted eviction
moratorium
that would focus just on counties with
higher rates
of of covid spread this is a president
who really understands
the heartbreak of eviction he is the
reason why he is pressing and pressing
even when legal authority looks slim is
because he wants to make sure we have
explored every
potential authority
these people are so filthy but they're
self-righteous
did you catch that we don't have the
legal authority to do what we're doing
but we're doing it anyway because who's
going to stop us republicans
mitch mcconnell please mark milly
doesn't report to mitch mcconnell
mitch mcconnell doesn't control the fbi
or the intelligence agencies
mitch mcconnell is unarmed what's he
going to do about it give a grumpy
speech and drive back to his condo
that's what they're saying that's what
criminals always say when they shake you
down at gunpoint and make no mistake
that's exactly what they're doing
because that's exactly who they are
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else